it's great to welcome to the program
today Roy Germano who is an author
documentary filmmaker and NYU professor
Roy has some great videos on his YouTube
channel where he is hanging out with a
rabbi a very charismatic rabbi in the
Crown Heights Brooklyn neighborhood and
so talk to us about that Roy I mean how
did how did that idea start of going you
actually go to one night of Hanukkah
with a family in Crown Heights how did
this all start it started with the tour
that the rabbi gives so I live in Crown
Heights I live about two subway stops
from where he lives and I just noticed
that he was giving these tours of his
neighborhood and I had always been
curious about Hasidic Jews having lived
in Brooklyn for ten years and also
feeling like people like me and people
like him don't usually talk so I took my
stepdaughter on the tour we we loved it
and through that Rabbi Katz and I
started hanging out like we would just
get coffee and talk about meaning of
life and stuff like that so I'm not
Jewish I'm not religious so it was just
it was just a great experience to talk
to somebody that I normally wouldn't be
talking to like that so one day we got
the idea to make a video of us hanging
out and it did pretty well on YouTube so
we decided to make more yeah and one of
the things I've talked about for years
is the the kind of mixed feeling I have
when you know I hear that a religious
conservative from Iowa who has been
anti-gay of politically for 20 years of
has finds out that they have a child who
is LGBT and then the view radically
changes because I know it touches them
personally and on the one hand it's
great that they are not so far gone that
a personal connection can't change their
mind but at the same time I wish it
didn't require that to be able to put
ourselves in the shoes of others and
imagine what it would be like so that
I'm curious to start with did your
experience hanging out with the Hasidic
Jewish community in Brooklyn did it
change your perspective in some sense on
any broader social or political issue
that might
late to that community yeah I mean what
you're describing is rooted in a social
psychology research there was a great
book called the nature of prejudice by
Gordon outport from the 50s and it's
really about this idea that it's hard to
hate somebody that you get to know
that's sort of my paraphrase of of
Albert's theory and I think it's true I
mean a lot of us have difficulty
imagining what life is like for others
so to spend time with them at the end of
the day we end up seeing that they're
not just a member of a group but they're
a human being and they're an individual
and they have you know their own
differences with that group and their
own similarities and you you can choose
to dislike them or like them on the
basis of them as an individual not as a
member of a group for me personally I
think by hanging out in the historic
neighborhood here in Crown Heights I've
just learned that the people who live
there are normal people I guess for me
and for a lot of people here in Brooklyn
you pass Hasidic people all the time and
you just assume that perhaps they think
and talk completely differently and then
when you sit down and you you realize
that you know we're all just sort of
trying to figure things out on our own
and they do it their way we do it our
way so I'd say that's been the number
one thing is just realizing that they're
like regular people just like you and me
a lot of the realizing that they're
regular people thing in terms of
American politics plays a huge role in
the immigration debate that that is now
being had you've spent time in Mexico
you talk about immigration a lot what is
the what are the ways in which the
experience with the Hasidic community in
Crown Heights has sort of informed or
made you think about what is happening
in terms of the immigration debate right
now particularly from Mexico and points
further south and central in Latin
America it's almost the reverse it's my
experience with Mexican and Central
American immigrants that that is in
foreign my approach to the hate crime
and an issue here in Crown Heights so
about 1560 however many years ago I was
a waiter in Chicago and I worked with a
lot of undocumented immigrants from
Mexico at that restaurant and to that
point in my life I had never met anybody
from Mexico and I never
at an undocumented person and so it was
like this process of realizing hey these
guys that I'm working with are just
normal people they're not the kind of
you know drug cartel
you know henchmen that you see and in
movies they didn't fit this stereotype
of Mexico that I had seen in the movies
throughout my life they were funny they
were kind they were intelligent they
were impressive people so it was through
that process of working at the
restaurant that I started to see the
humanity of immigrants and and just
really spent a big part of my career
going to Mexico learning about the
immigration issue and and then
eventually making films about it to kind
of bring that information back here to
the United States so this Crown Heights
project is really just an extension of a
project that I started in Mexico fifteen
years ago when I look at the
conversations that happen about
immigration in politics whether you're
looking at left or right there are some
themes that always come up what it what
is the right number of people that
should be allowed in what are we allowed
to do what should we be doing at the
border in terms of protection how much
of a focus should overstayed visas be
which source countries should we give
preference to in terms of allowing
people and for me the the big thing
that's missing is the discussion of what
is it that is generating the desire to
come to the United States in different
countries and it seems to me that
actually putting resources into dealing
with that may do way more than any of
the other piecemeal things that are
being heavily debated what's your sense
of that and what what are the broader
broader sort of economic questions
around the issue of immigration exactly
I think you've hit the nail on the head
there that when I would go to Mexican
communities back when I was doing my PhD
research I would hear the same story
over and over it was usually something
like we used to grow X crop then
suddenly almost overnight the price of
that crop fell in half and then people
here could no longer make a living and
so that that price drop that people were
talking about was usually related to
larger changes in the global economy
sort of the neoliberal ization of the
global economy the loosening of
regulations the cutting of social
welfare welfare program
and literally that the first community
ever went to in Mexico was a coffee
growing community and people would talk
about how the price dropped overnight
and when I looked at the larger changes
that were happening I saw that that had
a lot to do with US foreign economic
policy and then later I would talk to
corn farmers and they would talk about
the price of corn dropping and I would
see that that would have a lot to do
with NAFTA and the export of US corn to
Mexico and importation into Mexico
so I started to get the sense that if
you even tweak small things in our in
our foreign economic policy with
countries like Mexico and Central
America you could see a vast reduction
in the number of people who are
migrating without documentation and then
the Central American case is is slightly
different because there's the violence
issue there but you can even look at how
our environmental policies contribute to
climate change which has contributed to
massive droughts in Central America that
if in turn made it harder for people to
make a living which then has resulted in
more people coming to the US so
everything's interconnected in that
sense I want to try to make an analogy
between immigration in the United States
- trade policy as it relates to China so
we now are dealing with the the trade
war that is being waged against China
and we hear about oh we have a trade
deficit and Donald Trump wants to fix
the trade deficit and it's a very micro
focus and if you step back you realize
that for decades we've had an economy
based on we want cheap stuff
manufactured overseas that that's sort
of the basis and that's a lot of the
reason why we have a trade deficit today
and if we fix the trade deficit all of
these other things will have to change
it won't necessarily be good or bad but
it will have to change and it's not
being accounted for in the same way the
analogy I would make to immigration in
the United States is that a lot of those
people that I see arguing for the for
the sort of strict right-wing policies
that that we've been seeing don't seem
to account for the reality of industries
that are heavily reliant on both the
documented and undocumented immigrant
labor and even if we take them at their
face that these are the lists of things
that they want to fix there seems to be
very little consideration
for the broader economic impact that
that would have and it's not you know
you start to get a little bit I don't
want to start saying look at the
restaurant industry and agriculture and
and sort of and and creating these
stereotypes necessarily but there's a
reality that certain industries would be
very different were it not for the
status quo that exists today how should
we be thinking about that at the
individual level and how should
policymakers think about that yeah this
is actually an area where I think that
there could be a lot of common ground
between Democrats and Republicans if you
do look at the ways in which some of our
communities depend upon immigrants I
made a documentary a few years ago when
I was working with Vice news about the
dairy industry in upstate New York and
that there's so many people actually
that are very politically conservative
their farm owners but they've come to
appreciate the contributions that
immigrants make to their community
because they know that they can't find
people to do entry-level dairy farming
work from the the local community but
there are so many people that actually
have the skills that are coming from
agricultural communities in Central
America and Mexico that are interested
in doing that work and it's just amazing
it goes back to what I said at the
beginning that it's hard to hate
somebody that you get to know you see
these politically conservative farmers
becoming
over the years very close with the
people that work on their farms I met
farmers who actually travel to Mexico to
go to weddings and and meet the extended
families of the people that have worked
on their farms for you know 10 or 20
years so in some sense I think that you
know you have that economic reality and
and we could come together on that but
also a process of getting to know each
other I think could could contribute to
to policy outcomes that lead to more
compassionate stance on immigration what
do you think the priorities should be in
terms of what the US can do and that
could be what we can do within our
borders but also we have the decisions
that we can make about how we want to
work with other countries that are
sources of immigration to the United
States is there lower the lowest hanging
fruit that you see that are the these
things should be done right away
you know it is tricky in terms of
working for example with certain Central
American countries I mean there's a huge
culture of corruption in a country like
Honduras for example where I did some
work but there are a number of
organizations down there that are
working to reduce gang violence so
working to bolster those organizations
and invest in those organizations there
are various educational organizations
like for example there's a organization
that I'm familiar with called Becca
which is a an organization in Honduras
that provides bilingual education to
young people and they've had such a
great record where none of their
students have migrated illegally to the
United States they found work in Central
America so I think working with those
organizations would be a great great
first step when it comes to the economic
arguments about immigrants are sending
money back to their home countries and
this is a drain on the United States I
sort of have two questions on that one
is is it true that it is a drain and do
we not have to account for the other
side of the equation which is that
particularly undocumented immigrants are
often paying into social welfare systems
that because they are undocumented they
will never take benefits out and are
actually bolstering some of those
systems economically yeah so I wrote a
book called outsourcing welfare it's all
about the money that immigrants sent to
their home countries and this really is
you know a massive source of aid to
developing countries throughout the
world not just Mexico and Central
America but throughout the world it's
worth three times more than the aid that
the world's richest countries donate to
the developing world so it's just a huge
huge source of income for for low and
middle-income countries I do get this
question a lot is it a drain on the
United States to see this money go out
you know compared to the GDP and the
size of the United States economy it's
really a drop in the bucket the amount
of money going out this money does
create jobs actually there's so many
startups in the FinTech world and of
course you have like Western Union and
MoneyGram and those businesses that make
a lot of money off the the transfer of
migrant money I do think they're fiche
be reduced yes at this just my
perspective on that and and then a lot
of times people are buying American
products even in in migrants homelands
with with this money so it's not like
the money completely goes away in terms
of the money that immigrants pay into
the system I actually interviewed the
chief statistician at the Social
Security Administration a few years ago
and he estimates that undocumented
immigrants pay about thirteen billion
dollars into the Social Security system
and they'll never see that money back
and the way that that happens is that a
lot of undocumented immigrants get jobs
using fake Social Security numbers and
then they're on normal payrolls and
they're getting paid a paycheck and out
of that money comes the payroll taxes
which go to the to the federal
government so and you know undocumented
immigrants pay all kinds of taxes as
well they pay you know sales taxes and
property taxes and in all that as well
so it's not like they're just living off
of the system as as many people would
want to believe last thing I want to
touch on whenever it is that the current
president leaves office whether it's in
January of 2021 or January of 2025 or
sometime in between or before at this
point it's anyone's guess when it's
going to happen what are the things that
most immediately should be reversed that
he has done when it comes to immigration
well I mean his his effect on the
immigration system is not just what he's
done in terms of hard policy but it's
kind of the chaos that he's created in
the system for example I have friends
and colleagues that work in refugee
resettlement and for them it's just sort
of an open question of what the heck is
gonna happen right nobody really knows
how many refugees are gonna be able to
resettle so he's managed to just really
gum up the works and create all kinds of
uncertainty so there's that I think the
wall for example it's just ridiculous
and I've been saying this for years I
made a video in 2010 that you can find
on YouTube of two Americans climbing the
wall in less than 18 seconds and I've
always called the wall a symbol in the
desert it's just this very expensive
symbol that some politicians want to
build so that they say that they're
doing something about the issue you
could take all of those bill
of dollars and invest that in
communities in a place like Honduras and
and see huge huge return on that
investment in terms of people's lives
being improved and then and fewer people
coming to the United States we've been
speaking with NYU professor Royce Romano
who's an author documentary filmmaker
you can check out some of his work by if
you are watching on YouTube checking out
the links down in the video description
roy such a pleasure having you on I
really appreciate your time thanks David
thanks so much